I had a moment from my nightmares and
the recent trip I had which is related
to this yeah um so I the reason I flew
back to America was to go to my wife's
family reunion uh so I've met her family
a bunch of times but also she has a
massive family like it's a big
Midwestern family so many cousins so
many uncles uh and I remember like
meeting like one of her cousins right
and I'll be honest she has a lot of
cousins I don't remember all of their
names I know it's I know like there's
like a pool of names uh I don't know
he's like one of those names you know
what I mean it's either like a uh Tommy
or a Ryan or a Tim or something it's
like in the pool of like names so I go
in and I've met him like a few times
before uh shake his hand and he goes hey
God nice to see you again I'm like Hey
man nice to meet you dead ass he like
shakes my hand looks me in the eye and
he goes what's my name
blue screened as a human I'm like
uh uh and then he's like ah don't worry
man don't worry about it it's Ryan and I
I realize now why he did that what if he
was like just kidding it's Tommy I told
you I realized because uh we had we had
like a party afterwards uh and uh some
some other like friends came over and uh
he was there uh and when they met Ryan
they're like oh hey Ryan I remember it
this time I actually remember it this
time so I think he says that to everyone
so nobody forgets his name and it
[__] worked because that like I think
he's instilled PTSD into me yeah I will
never now never forget his name when I
see him I mean it's it's a bit of a
double-edged sword because now everyone
who is associated with Ryan knows who
Ryan is but at the same time I feel a
lot of people are gonna be like what an
[__] I can't believe you just put me
on the spotlight I mean I mean yeah uh
yeah that's like I that's the thing you
like you see in your nightmare they
actually happening I'm like oh no oh no
but luckily luckily we go we got like
the good ending that's good uh just
gonna put me through like personal
trauma
yeah my manager calls everybody since it
even like in like an honorful way and
also like a friend would be like like
hey boss or like yeah hey boss you know
she uses it for everybody she uses it
for me too I'm like you don't know my
name
I do the equivalent in English where I
just call everyone dude like it doesn't
matter like it doesn't matter like how
many times I've met you what gender you
are what age you are like I'll call a 90
year old grandma dude like I'm just like
just so I can get out of the situation
and be like I apologize I don't remember
your name but I want to be friendly with
you so I'll just throw it I'll start
it's the magical word to just be like oh
yeah no he's cool with me yeah does he
know my name though I don't know
probably not have you ever met someone
and you're like uh you know they they
refer to you as like dude or someone or
you like you just know that they do not
know your name oh yeah oh definitely
yeah and I know it's like I don't want
to be an [__] about it but because
I've been in that situation so many
times but sometimes you there's a look
in their eye you know where there's like
the slight like Panic where I'm like I
hope he doesn't I'm I'm actually really
sympathetic for people who do that
because I'm exactly the same right so
like you know any chance I can get like
I'll maybe like throw in my name or like
Clues to my name like yeah in the
conversation do that as well you know
like sometimes like I'd be telling a
story about like you know an anecdote
about something that happened to me and
then I'll switch to like third person
being like Joey you [__] up to be like
quickly grab it yeah I said my name
remember it I'm like I'm like you see
like the light wall pops up yeah and
they're like oh that's his name
yeah so that's like a little thing I
like to do because you know I get it I
wish people did that more for me
sometimes I do like the alley-oop yeah
okay so uh so there's been times when I
know my wife can't remember her name uh
and I do like the alley-oop I just like
call to them or something like that yeah
yo yo Rob how are you doing and you know
I I know I know Sydney's listening to
that point so you know if sometimes
sometimes people do that to me as well
and it's just like all right everyone
gets it yeah but okay to be fair you
have a very memorable name
I've met a lot of Joey's in my life you
are the only one and only God I have met
in my life my biggest problem is making
sure people actually can pronounce my
name once they get the pronunciation
then most of the time they remember it
yeah sure do you have a technique of
like when you you're in the industry and
you don't know someone's name do you use
the Sensei technique or I run past them
as fast as I could as if I'm in a hurry
like I'm like checking my phone like
let's get someone else because I don't
want to be rude so um I usually like
pretend I'm only running because I'm
late to something yeah I would talk to
you if I had the time but I can't I'm
sorry
kind of personal question people really
uh social anxiety uh have you ever
pretended to be on the phone yes okay
you do that as well and also a very life
hack if you're left with somebody that
you you feel really uncomfortable with
or like you're really nervous I put my
timer for like two minutes and then I
like leave it on the table and then it
rings and I'm like oh I got a phone call
I gotta go I'm just I gotta go
[Laughter]
that's so good I gotta take this
dude like I'm like giving all these like
tips and tricks to like get out of the
situation sounds just like I'm a [__]
dick I'm not even I'm not even in this
right now I'm just gonna go online
that's so funny well I guess um yeah
like you know none of them like what
what what's your guys's uh next steps
like what do you have going up we have a
second album coming out in November 22nd
oh yeah and we have an online talk event
as well uh yeah so if you guys are
interested please come oh yeah bye yeah
hell yeah do you have anything else you
want I mean you've seen it seems like
you've done so much already is there
anything else you want to do or like a
role in voice acting or like a project
that you like dream of getting oh
oh gosh
would you just explode at that point I
mean there would have to be like an
ambulance there every week
to be fair yeah so Tyler are there any
like uh future events we can see you at
or your fans can see you at
um I'm actually going to be the emcee
for aof
2023.00
public speaking
yeah any Plex on Lane Fest 2023. it's
happening on September 9th
99. now I won't ever forget it
yeah
from 8pm
we're going to be announcing a lot of
new antiplex titles yeah a lot of new
informations like twice if you are okay
yeah okay if I'm okay okay
blink twice if you're not okay
[Laughter]
and uh you know uh with that event as
well I think uh there might be even like
a little secret like trash taste
appearance maybe I don't know if you
know how long the event's gonna be last
year was like five hours this is the
fourth time this year I've been the
emcee for four consecutive years so
you're gonna be there is that all
scripted or do you get to like
um go upstairs
script a little bit but yeah yeah really
on time and we have a lot of artists
coming too awesome yeah right on yes
wish you the best of luck yeah I hope
your contact lens there's a little bit
more I will go in my glasses and they're
still gonna fall off and crack